the tears i shared upon my cheek
pose a question
whose hands do i see
why you are not me from tearful memories
to fallen friends
and incredible stories of valor veterans
are embedded in the fabric of our nation
every single one of these tags has a
story of heroism behind it what makes us
great is that
it's in those moments that what we like
to say in the military stand in the gap
from unsung heroes to those who stood
tall in the face of peril
tonight we share their stories celebrate
their lives and remember their
sacrifices
tonight we honor the voices of veterans
welcome and we thank you for joining us
for our veterans voices special as we
honor those who serve i'm sasha loftis
veterans day is right around the corner
and while it's well known here in the
u.s there are still some misconceptions
about the holiday tonight tarvarius
haywood breaks down the five facts you
need to know
there's enough confusion about veterans
day that the u.s department of defense
is highlighting five important facts
about the holiday the first thing to
remember there is no apostrophe in
veterans day the day honors all veterans
so no apostrophe is needed number two
veterans day and memorial day are two
different distinct holidays celebrated
in different ways memorial day honors
those who gave their lives for our
country veterans day honors everyone
dead or alive who served and is largely
extended to thank living vets for their
sacrifice
our third and fourth facts get into the
history of the holiday veterans day was
originally called armistice day to
commemorate the end of world war one
after world war ii and the korean war
congress changed armistice day to
veterans day which is now celebrated on
november 11th and rounding out the top
five veterans day is celebrated
worldwide in different ways for instance
canada australia and great britain have
remembrance day in november honoring
vets in similar fashion
that was tarvarius haywood reporting
it's been 77 years since the d-day
invasion where thousands of americans
put their lives on the line without the
promise of coming home and many didn't
but june 6 1944 was a day that marked a
turning point in world war ii it also
marked a significant moment for so many
young soldiers heather mills shares the
story of a local man who fought in that
battle he says it's when he became a man
and though it took more than seven
decades he finally has a tangible token
to remember his perseverance
i'm just a foot soldier that's all
humble words from a man who was part of
the d-day invasion storming the beach in
normandy during the landing i was
i caught a piece of shrapnel on my knee
fighting through that injury to make it
to the battle of the bulge months later
now i stay with the outfit inofrio
zakiri no no as he's called says during
the chaos his wound was never documented
even after it got infected and another
medic had to help he kept fighting and
it remained off the books
77 years later
recognition for his courage i finally
got it and this is it here
i finally got it
my purple heart las vegas mayor carolyn
goodman and an army representative
presented ono with the oldest military
award also naming him october citizen of
the month
nono says it was his kids who pushed him
to pursue the medal he's a father of six
they felt like
i deserved it a first generation
american nono says he was a shoemaker by
trade than a milkman when he first moved
his family to las vegas he took up
woodworking something he still enjoys i
get that it kept me out of the casinos
nono who turns 99 in december was
drafted at age 19. for years i tried to
forget the war but now he fondly
remembers the friends he made
and the ones he lost that's rallo
here i am here
me and john
that's tex
a proud veteran a proud american america
believe it heather mills live local now
a new exhibit is now open in downtown
henderson as a way to honor local
veterans
it's a story of service service to
others before yourself and i think
that's the whole project's goal is to
help others realize that
as a country we need to come together
and serve others
michael conrad was inspired by his uncle
four years ago who shared stories of his
time in the military so he began taking
these portraits of local servicemen
vintage american flags and artwork
created by veterans is also on display
you can check it out inside henderson
city hall just beautiful
and the art exhibits continue one
colorado veteran says he found a way to
serve his country after his time in the
service zach smith believes he
discovered his art skills by accident
his studio is his garage where he's
designed thousands of unique and
patriotic paintings by his count there's
about 8 000 pieces of his art out there
in the world the gift of this colorful
work might be most cherished though by
families who are in their darkest hour
it's humbling to me that i have a way
that i can personally give back
his mission now give back to military or
first responder families that have had a
loved one die in the line of duty he
does a special piece for every fallen
brother or sister and sadly the work has
kept him busy so far he's remembered
more than 20 families of the fallen with
a keepsake that honors their hero in a
way that nothing else can
the pentagon is home to the u.s
department of defense but 20 years ago
it was defenseless against a hijacked
airplane in the iconic building's
toughest time service members took
action and as john rogers shows us they
willingly answered the call wherever it
took them
when men and women swear the oath to
defend our nation they're prepared to
face any danger this country may face
even if it comes right to their doorstep
on september 11 2001 daniel fall was a
second class petty officer working for
the secretary of the navy his office was
at the pentagon and at 9 37 the world
stopped
i heard a loud explosion i stopped
my my ears were ringing terribly people
were scrambling
some were
what looked like burned uniforms were
tattered
you know soot marks fall and thousands
of others made their way to safety but
sadly some of his friends didn't they
were killed in the terrorist attack
undeterred fall and many others went
right back to work the next day while
firefighters were still on the scene the
building never stopped operating and the
mission didn't end there fall and many
others immediately answered the call to
serve at ground zero fall spent three
weeks in the shadow of the trade
center's ruins helping doctors and first
responders what makes us great is that
it's in those moments that we that are
still here rise up
and we what we like to say in the
military stand in the gap that dark day
will forever stick with fall but he
doesn't focus on the negative he
remembers it as a time when the military
stood up to a challenge and succeeded
for veterans voices i'm john rogers
coming up next here on veterans voices
giving back to our warriors the local
gym helping veterans find strength and
camaraderie stay with us
welcome back a virginia veteran is
making sure our fallen heroes are not
forgotten retired army ranger james
howard was paralyzed in a diving
accident when he's not helping disabled
children learn to ride bikes he's
commemorating fallen veterans with a dog
tag memorial it honors the more than 7
000 troops lost during the global war on
terror and with requests coming in every
week howard has a plan
we get requests from phoenix san diego
san francisco all over out west
and it would just be great i think to
bring that kind of reflection out in
that area
this year his homemade memorial was put
on display in new york city for the
anniversary of 9 11. next year howard
plans to add the names of the 13 service
members killed in afghanistan in an
attack outside the airport in kabul
helping our wounded warriors find their
inner strength through a crossfit gym
branded one crossfit is the first and
only non-profit gym in las vegas it
offers free memberships to veterans
while they work out with the community
victoria saha takes us through their
mission
when we come across a veteran we often
say thank you for your service but a
branded one crossfit veterans are being
offered more than just a thanks they're
offered a free gym membership the
welcoming and the atmosphere in here is
what
made me want to come back here edward
haynes was in the marine corps for 20
years finding his way back to civilian
life wasn't the easiest keeping kind of
a community
has been
beneficial in keeping some of my sanity
you know finding mike like minded
individuals in a place other than
like a bar crossfit is a form of high
intensity training haynes says it
reminds him of the brotherhood he felt
trying to accomplish a goal with other
marines when serving knowing that we're
going to share
some of the struggle again
you know
because struggle brings about a lot of
camaraderie are these your favorite
exercises
yeah
all right let's go haynes lets me join
in on a session along with equipment the
gym has soldier boots right at the
entrance and an american flag proudly
hanging adding to the welcome for those
who served what we want to do is get
them out of the house get them doing
something that's productive getting out
of their heads releases a lot of stress
and it helps you feel better
and that carries on for several hours
after you're done studies show since
2001 114 thousand vets have died by
suicide a scary statistic but branded
one is hoping to give our service men
and women another mission in life
besides carrying the weight of the
country it's not just about them though
right it's about bringing just regular
community members into the gym so that
hopefully they can just feel like
they're a part of a normal community
disabled or not the gym has a spot
waiting for any veteran victoria saha
live local now
now in honor of veterans day the gym
will hold its biggest fundraising event
with a workout challenge on november
13th we have registration information on
our website
eightnewsnow.com
coming up next here on veterans voices
proud army veteran and celebrated
hometown hero we'll meet one soldier who
stepped up to serve his country 80 years
ago and continues to give back to his
colorado community today his touching
story is next
veterans from across the country are
traveling to dc once again after the
pandemic grounded honor flights for 18
months the nonprofit gives all expenses
paid trips to those who served during
the world war ii korea and vietnam eras
so they can visit the memorials honoring
them washington correspondent jesse
tanner reports
god bless the united states a hero's
welcome thank you sir for 122 veterans
at the memorials dedicated to honoring
their service and sacrifice
strangers at the national mall asked for
photos and shook their hands
while some families celebrated
generations of military service in d.c
together
this honor flight from columbus ohio
gave those who served during the world
war ii korea and vietnam eras an all
expenses paid trip to reunite with those
who survived and remember those who
didn't real joy to be out here today
bill lawson served in the navy during
the vietnam war a time when he said many
returned home to a much different
reception being cursed and spat on and
and i think this is just a wonderful way
to show we appreciate every military
person the pandemic grounded all honor
flights for 18 months precious time for
some veterans who were hoping to take
the trip but passed away before they
could there's not
that you can ask a lot of questions
bill jackson was the only world war ii
veteran on this honor flight he served
in the navy where he manned a gun turret
come countries and couplings put 20
holes in her ship so
yeah
at 96 years old jackson still has vivid
memories of the war but was first
reluctant to make the trip back to the
memorial that honors it are you glad you
did
oh yeah
they've been so nice for me i can't
believe it for veterans voices i'm jesse
chinor
he served his country 80 years ago now
he's stepping up once again to help his
community an army veteran who just
turned 100 years old answering the call
to action jeremy hubbard has his story
dear mr blake thank you so much for
taking the time today
to read my letter fan mail is not the
sort of thing most 100 year olds are
used to getting there are not enough
words to express my deep appreciation
for you and all others who have served
our nation but over the years notes from
total strangers have appeared in george
blake's mailbox thank you so much truly
means a lot to me with gratitude for his
role in history 80 years ago
he was stationed at pearl harbor
december 7th i was only there a few
minutes 1941 and there was this
tremendous sound
the day america was thrust into world
war ii we came out of the building the
sky was falling planes more than 2400
americans died in that attack i suddenly
realized
they were all kids and you could say a
little part of george 1912
died that day too
why you and not me a few years ago he
wrote a poem that he still can't get
through without tears i gaze at the list
of the young who died
and with plenty motions
i have cried
the tears i shed upon my cheek
poser questioned whose answer i seek
why you are not me
george is the last pearl harbor survivor
in his small colorado county one of the
last in the entire country which
probably explains that fan mail very
much so and the neighbors is very
special who consider him george is very
unique he's a special dude a local
celebrity we had a second one in town
but he died probably 10 or 12 years ago
not to mention an outright hero you know
he does make a difference
it's a reputation solidified even
further a few months ago when this old
veteran set out on a journey to serve
once again seems a friend who works with
a local charity told george there was a
veteran in britain who went on a hundred
walks to support health care workers
george's friend had an idea he said
would you get a hundred walks in by your
birthday can you do that
i said i think so so i did
did he ever for more than three months
leading up to his 100th birthday in the
thin mountain air seven thousand feet
above sea level there he was every day
people come by and say what walk was
this i said oh 31st to the 65th
to my 100th birthday and on his birthday
he's the one who gave the present to his
hometown more than 10 thousand dollars
raised through his walks to help a local
nonprofit serving families during the
pandemic i didn't mind doing it i was
walking anyway and i was able and that's
the important thing of being a veteran
anyway ask anyone around here is to do
what you can to make a difference in
your community they'll tell you he's one
of the very few
world war ii veterans still left from
pearl harbor to his front patio service
is who george blake is thank you again
for your time today it's no wonder
they're all such big fans that would be
a tremendous surprising gift for
veterans voices i'm jeremy hubbard
george had hoped to return to hawaii
this december for the 80th anniversary
ceremony at pearl harbor but a minor
health issue is keeping him home this
year however he still takes those walks
every chance he gets
it's not every day that you get a fire
engine fanfare and a parade for your
birthday but bakersfield resident betty
patrice isn't just anyone she's 106
years old and a world war ii veteran she
jumped into action and enlisted in the
navy after the 1941 attack on pearl
harbor at the time only men could serve
in most naval branches so she joined up
with waves a service that enlisted women
nearly 80 years later she's still
tight-lipped about the classified
projects she dove into she did reveal
the keys to longevity though live a good
clean life and have a happy family
when we think of veterans we often think
about their roles as combat soldiers or
in technical support of war but there
are thousands of other rules some are
musicians born into a musical family
roger dickerson was drafted after
graduating with a master's degree his
new mission to play in the 44th army
band a position he took to heart
you're serving your country and and we
all
were trying to do it the best that we
could and what we did we were musicians
dickerson and the army band spent
significant time in germany playing but
it's when he came home that his work
really took shape he eventually became a
composer and educator training future
generations in the art of music
still ahead one man's mission to honor
heroes
i'm an old army combat engineer ask us
to do something impossible we will try
more on a seemingly impossible task and
why this veteran wants to make sure the
valor of his fellow servicemen is never
forgotten
welcome back search your name on the
internet and you might uncover something
unexpected it happened to army veteran
mark deville and what he found was life
changing he discovered he was a silver
star recipient one of the highest honors
for valor in combat and he never even
knew it that recognition is all thanks
to doug sterner he spends as much as 16
hours a day compiling a massive database
on a website called home of heroes it
documents roughly
275 000 recipients of the nation's
highest military honors
i thought well it would be an impossible
task i said it can't be done but i'm an
old army combat engineer ask us to do
something impossible we will try
sterner says tracking down what he calls
forgotten valor is personal he wanted to
recall the heroism of a friend killed in
vietnam and make sure his bravery was
never lost since then his mission has
been clear give the same due diligence
to those who may have fallen through the
cracks he's rifled through millions of
records over the years doing the
herculean task many thought the military
was already doing while that may be true
it's not an easy job and sometimes not
all veterans want the recognition
when you get a medal for heroism it's
not something you want to talk about
that medal that you got represents the
worst day of your life and that's why
they're lost to history
cerner estimates there are still 150 000
names that need to be added to his
database if you'd like to search his
records for the name of a loved one
visit homeofheroes.com
finally here tonight as we've said
veterans day is quickly approaching on
november 11th there's a woman who wants
to honor the men and women who have
dedicated their lives to our country don
cramer's father who was a korean veteran
is buried at the boulder city memorial
cemetery when kramer visited her dad's
gravesite in 2019 and didn't see flags
she decided to take on the task herself
last year kramer replaced more than 1
000 flags this year she has 5 000 flags
that's so far
and i could come out there on my own
diamond play out there and put three
flights on my dad's grave and call him
today but i can't walk past all those
men and women who fought for my freedom
and gave their service to our country
and and not be able to think great you
know they're being honored today
but you know what it's gonna get done
it's just gonna take time
kramer is looking for help you can call
the local ace hardware store in boulder
city to order more flags
and that's it for us here we thank you
so much for joining us as we share these
incredible voices of veterans each of
them offering a unique snapshot of their
lives and telling stories of bravery
loss and the triumph of the human spirit
we hope you enjoyed and have a wonderful
veterans day i'm sasha loftis good night
[Music]
you